Hi.
Today I want to talk about
learning a language from scratch.
Remember, if you enjoy these videos,
please subscribe and you can click
on the bell for notifications.
And I am going to talk today
about how I use LingQ to
start a language from scratch.
Now I have, this is kind of
the fourth in this series of
videos on studying effectively.
And one of the themes that you will have
heard throughout each of these videos is
the importance of listening and reading.
So then people say, well, how can I listen
and read, uh, with a language that I
know nothing about, like from scratch,
how do you start listening and reading?
So I thought it would be useful to go off,
to go over some of the basic principles,
what I do when I'm starting from scratch.
Because very recently I
have started from scratch.
In Persian in Arabic, in Turkish,
in Greek, uh, you know, I tend
to remember all the languages
that I've started from scratch.
And the way I start from scratch is
that I use the Mini Stories and I
use the Mini Stories because there
is so much repetition in each story.
So you have 60 stories where
within each story, there is lots
of repetition, the same vocabulary
repeats five times within the story.
One of the problems with more conventional
learner books, starter books is that
while it may, it pretends to be easier in
fact, not a lot of the vocabulary repeats
within the lesson, or even later on in the
book and we do need vocabulary to repeat
if we're going to have a
chance to remember it also.
Uh, I will demonstrate I'll show you
myself learning Indonesian from scratch.
Now, I had some brief exposure to
Indonesian and because my wife and
I, uh, in 1975, we were in Bali.
So I remember a few words
like, um,..., "how much?"
Or ... "thank you".
And I remember being in an airplane
and I heard ... which is ladies
and gentlemen, but that's about it.
Uh, so I will demonstrate how I start
from scratch, uh, with the Mini Stories
and one of the things that I'll point
out in the Mini Stories is, while most
people go from lesson one to lesson two
to lesson three, the language is the
language, the language isn't so much
less than one lesson, two lesson three.
It's not obvious that less than five
is more difficult than lesson one.
The very high frequency words will
appear in lesson one and lesson two
and lesson three and lesson four and
lesson five and 10 and 20 and 30.
So with that, I'd like you
to have a look at me, sort of
dealing with Indonesian in LingQ.
We are, uh, I'm in Persian right now
doing this very interesting podcast in
Persian, but I want to sort of experience
going to a language for the first time.
So we're going to change the language
and we're going to go to something
that I haven't done, practically,
haven't done anything on Indonesian.
Okay.
I got two words in Indonesian and I think
I spent some time just looking at it,
just exploring it to see what's there.
So in the library, I mean,
let's see my lessons.
I guess I, I looked at the Mini Stories
and I looked at this other thing.
I was curious, Buddha, but let's
go to the Mini Stories because
starting a language from scratch.
Uh, that's what I would do.
So if we look at our statistics, 97%
of the words in here are new to me.
The reason it's 97, because I
remember I did look at a lesson
and looked up a few words.
Uh, here is story one.
So if we look up story one and I want
to point out something that I think is
quite important, and which I mentioned
earlier is when you're starting in a
language, you don't have to start at one.
You don't have to start
necessarily at "how are you?"
Uh, father, mother, sister, brother.
Um, the present tense isn't
necessarily easier than the past tense.
There is no real order.
So I think we're conditioned to want
to go story one, story two, story
three, but it doesn't really matter.
Um, if I look at story one here, you
will see that I did spend some time,
I don't know when looking at
this, I looked at these words.
I don't remember any of these words.
I did this just as an experiment some time
ago, but what I'm going to do instead is
I'm going to go to the next lesson and
let's assume that we start on lesson two.
Some of the words that showed up in
lesson one will be here in lesson two.
And so the whole thing about
starting from scratch is you just
want to discover the language.
I could look up a grammar book
and get some hints as to how the
language works, uh, from, you know,
subject, uh, subject verb, noun or
whatever, but it doesn't matter.
We're just going to explore.
So this first word ... means
following, next.
Okay.
... so the following is a story....
now this is a capital, so I'm assuming
it's a person's name ... and okay.
... Okay.
So you have to assume
that this is "winter".
So I'm just going to
discover the language.
So the following is a story about
Puji and Liburan and her holiday...
in her winter holidays.
Okay.
Now I have an advantage in doing
the Mini Stories in that I've done
them in so many different languages.
Okay.
Puji...
okay, she's obviously excited.
... so this obviously is another way of
saying "winter" or "winter vacation"...
so by looking these words up, I can
actually follow the meaning here.
So what I would normally do, and I
should point out too, that in terms of
dictionaries, I'm using Bob blah, I could
look up, you know, again, it depends
what, what your native language is.
You can choose from a variety of
addiction areas, some languages
will have more than others.
Uh, what does this say?
So this looks to be a dictionary
entirely in Indonesian.
May not be so meaningful for me.
I don't think I'll use it again.
Maybe at a later stage.
So I close this.
So I'm going to stay with, let's
see, what did Babla give me?
Yeah here.
So this gives me more information.
I'm going to stay with
Babla and Google translate.
Okay.
I can do one more sentence now.
Of course, I can listen to this.
In fact, what I would normally do,
I should point out is that I would
go and do this in sentence mode.
That way I can look at
it sentence by sentence.
Okay.
So here I take this sentence and
I might spend some time there
or I go to the next sentence.
Uh, it says, uh, met my daily target.
You can set your own target.
I don't worry about those
things, but some people like it.
Okay.
So, I mean, I I'm going through these,
these words will all be status one and
I won't go through the whole thing.
I mean, I can do the next sentence.
Whoops.
That wasn't what I wanted
to do, uh, wherever here.
Okay.
So here again.
So I would normally, and I think
that's enough here of, of going
through the Mini Stories here.
Uh, and, and let me explain a little
bit, uh, how I would use these Mini
Stories and how it eventually enables
me to break into the language.
All right.
So it gives you a bit of a sense that,
that I begin my contact with a new
language by just discovering what's there.
Uh, some languages have the
verb at the end, some languages
have the verb in the middle.
And some books will tell you this, but
actually as you go through discovering
the language, translating each word,
if necessary, translating a phrase,
you start to discover the language.
So if typically what I would do is I
would pick my way through one story.
Then I would listen to it.
Uh, I can listen to it and by the way,
I would do the story in sentence mode.
Definitely it's much easier
to do in sentence mode.
And then you can listen to each sentence.
And after having worked your way
through and looked up words and what
I didn't show in the demonstration
was using the flashcards.
Typically I would, whenever I turn the
page, I would do some flash carding while
those words are still fresh in my mind.
And having done all of that, if
I then go away and listen to the
story, I won't understand much.
Okay.
That's the reality.
And so then I have to go back
and I read it again and pretty...
and after reading it again and looking up
words again and going through flashcards
again, uh, then I go and listen to
it and I still don't understand much.
And, but then I will move
on to the next lesson.
And I typically will go in sequence,
but you don't have to, uh, but it's
better to go in sequence because
then you remember what you've done.
Uh, so normally I would start with
lesson one and then lesson two
and lesson three and so forth.
And I'll understand 20% eventually,
you know, I'll start to understand
10, 20, 30% I keep on doing this,
but I also, and in fact, it's been
proven based on, you know, research
and cognitive processes in our brain,
don't spend your whole time trying
to nail down lesson one as the
efficiency declines very quickly.
Uh, rather you should move on
to the next lesson because even
another lesson that you don't
understand is still a new lesson.
The brain likes novelty.
So I typically will spend a fair
amount of time on lesson one,
understand after a while, understand,
I understand more and more when reading
it with the help of a dictionary.
Uh, listening without reading.
Uh, I understand very little, but
then I keep on moving forward.
Lesson two, lesson three,
lesson four, lesson five, then
I'll go back to lesson one.
And by the time you reach lesson 10,
lesson one, which you've now listened to
15 times, it's starting to make sense.
And that's basically the process
combination of listening while
reading in sentence mode.
Uh, looking at words, looking
at words again and again.
Uh, reviewing words and
flashcards after each page.
And then of course, a lot of listening
away from it, not understanding an
awful lot, but now you're more and
more curious, like, what is that
meaning that I can't seem to remember?
And you go by and all of a sudden,
as was the case for me with say
Persian and Arabic, which have
a much more difficult script.
I mean, Indonesian has the advantage
that it's written in the Latin alphabet.
But I did this for Persian and Arabic.
Now I will also get myself a book, Teach
Yourself, or, you know, Colloquial.
Because it's, it's nice to cover
the same material in different ways.
So I'll read through it and they'll
have some different monologues
or dialogues per each lesson.
And they'll explain some things about the
language, which might be useful to me.
I won't fully be able to use those
explanations, but it all, it's all part
of my gradually discovering the language.
I should say that Indonesian
would be an attractive one to do.
I'm not about to abandon Persian and
Arabic, but Indonesian is spoken by,
I think if we add in Malaysia and
Indonesia, 200 million people.
Uh, I think that are common
words with, uh, with...
I'm not sure, uh, it's an
important part of the world.
It's an important language.
Uh, it's meant to be easy.
Uh, I don't know if that's true
or not, but, uh, certainly the
writing system is easy for us.
Uh, there are no tones to deal with.
So it's one that I may very well go and
learn later on, but I think it's, it's an
easy one to use as a demonstration of how
to start a language, uh, from scratch.
And I can assure you, I use the
same process in much more difficult
languages like Persian and Arabic.
The important thing is not to get
worried about what you don't understand
trust the fact that the brain will
eventually start to form some patterns,
will eventually start to understand it.
It seems at first impossible, and
it seemed as, particularly for
me, uh, with the Persian, with the
Arabic script, you know, impossible.
Uh, but you just have to stay with it.
You just have to stay with
it and keep listening.
And I end up listening to these stories
30, 40, 50 times, but not all at once,
not listening to it over and over again,
trying to force myself to understand it.
I go through it and, and, and
continue, and then go back and and
sometimes I'll listen to the, uh,
you know, there is a function at
LingQ "listen to the course audio".
So that'll be set up on my iPhone.
I can listen to it.
I can shuffle it.
And slowly, slowly, slowly, all
of this starts to make sense.
Once you have a base, as in say the Mini
Stories you can then branch off into
more difficult, um, you know, authentic
content that you might run to import from
somewhere, or you can find in our library.
Uh, but I think the Mini Stories,
because there's so much repetition and,
and remember, you don't need to ace the
most frequent 500 words, they're going
to show up anyway, they will show up.
Don't worry about it.
Uh, you have to recognize that there
is going to be a long period where
you have to acquire these, you know,
relatively less frequent words,
uh, and which are very important
to the meaning of any context.
Uh, however, the, the, the
Mini Stories is a place where
I get a start in the language.
I get a sense of the language.
I get some basic vocabulary,
some basic phrasing.
Now I'm ready to start exploring
beyond that, but that's how the sort
of listening and reading starting from
scratch when you know nothing about
the language, that's how I do it.
So I hope that was helpful.
And, uh, I, I'm going to offer
you a couple of videos that kind
of follow along in the same vein.